ah this is stressful game those are
people there's a people I'm gonna go say
hi to the people hi hi I'm gonna call
you Smitty and I'm gonna call you
Buehrle again all right I found friends
we didn't kill me right off the bat you
disgusting some over there are you gonna
betray me okay good all right you're not
gonna betray me
aah Oh Oh world will know of your
betrayals many werben jaegerman jensen
they were my friends
they betray me I knew they would stab me
in the back I'll just have to stab them
in the back I'll stab them in the butt
that's what I'll do
Oh if I find a gun in this house you're
gonna get it whoa did they ever make a
mistake to mess with me I'm gonna getcha
Smitty there don't you run away from me
I'm a mouse key yeah I'm the greatest I
kill my only friends you zombie
apocalypse they kill biodefense yeah I
can't live with my shame I can't live
with my shame I can live with my shame
hey they attacked me first it's their
bad luck that they just happened to dump
me where I was gonna find a frickin
assault rifle whose fault is it whose
fault is it
what's I look like I look like a
jerk gonna I'm gonna go say hi to the
people hey guys hey I'm trying to
survive I'm not actually lethal I just
like to pop out of walls and go ooh are
you serious what do you mean I mean you
clearly know more powerful spells than
that